[Music]
let's make a mai tai one of the most
misunderstood cocktails out there see
all kinds of recipes with tropical fruit
juice pineapple mango guava there really
should be now that in my time there's
just four ingredients Jamaican rum lime
juice orange Curacao and borgia we're
going to start with our or Jacques half
an ounce and we're going to build it all
in our mixing glass right here all shot
is a syrup made from almonds and it's
the key ingredient in a mai tai you see
a lot of them that are more for coffee
and so they can be sort of thickened
marzipan tea it really should just taste
like sweet toasted almonds so look for
something like that
now half an ounce of orange Curacao
something high-quality if you can it
lasts a long time it makes a big
difference now some lime juice which of
course we're going to juice fresh 3/4
ounce lime juice and finally we're going
to add our Jamaican style room it
doesn't have to be from Jamaica because
they make all kinds of rum there it's
more that it needs to be an aged rum
that has some real robust earthy flavors
which to make its known for that cuts
the sweetness of some of the sweeter
ingredients and add some real depth to
the cocktail so two ounces Jamaican
style rum and that is it we are ready to
shake fill your shaker with ice and
shake for about ten seconds all right
we're going to strain this drink into a
rocks glass
the smaller ice cubes you have the
better because it really helps to chill
the drink down but if you don't have
crushed ice that's no big deal just
maybe crack a few cubes on top now to
garnish this I really think tropical
drinks are a blank canvas I'm just going
to do a lime wheel and this little
umbrella you can use a mint sprig a
piece of sugar cane piece of ripe fruit
whatever seems right to you if you liked
this video and you're looking for more
tips to step up your bartending game
subscribe to the GT u channel if that
lots more where that came from
[Music]